today's new member of the day is Jacob
Timmons Jacob thank you for being a
member and supporter thanks to Jennifer
Lavoie who's today's long-term
sustaining member of the day join them
by signing up at
www.cannainsider.com/trends
three percent will prioritize experience
in Prior political office so not
particularly surprising I would expect
that most of our audience would be
voting in 2020 in the 2020 Democratic
primary on the basis of issues and I'm
glad to see that but also 20 percent
electability sounds about right to me
I've said that I'm primarily focused on
positions and political issues in
ideology but that as we get closer and
closer to the primary dates in our
respective states evaluating
electability to some degree is sort of
just something that that you have to do
although we don't want to let that
calculation completely dictate every
decision that we make so not surprising
results and we will continue to do
polling of the audience on 20/20
candidates
in the future and hopefully once we
actually feel as though we have every
candidate that we know every candidate
who is going to be running we can even
do an informal David Pakman show poll as
to who is our audience supporting and I
actually am unsure who would come out on
top on that one new poll next week
probably I'll let you know when it's up